[Applaudissements]
non nos marges avait dit simplement dans
un bouquin sur la télé que j'avais un
copain et c'est vrai un copain que j'ai
connu en normandie et charcutiers et qui
est de 10 ou 100 mené 2 buts
voilà ce départ mais n'ont donc puis il
a cru je m'occupe pas du tout et
d'ailleurs je vais aller le voir parce
qu'il a un one man show qui commence
bientôt
il ya des gens vous n'aimez pas ou dont
vous dites du mal des fois ça peut vous
arriver ou pas non les gens il ya trois
catégories meilleur album sûrement mon
avis dans ce métier il ya trois
catégories de gens et sont sur la
troisième génération qui a su qu
beaucoup de talent et qu'on aurait
préféré ne pas connaître parce qu
humainement ils sont pâles au niveau de
leur talent gérard connaît comme moi il
ya c'est donc il ya ceux qui n'ont aucun
talent et qui sont imbuvables n'en parle
même pas et puis un cercle très fermé
des gens qui ont beaucoup de talent et
qui sont des gens biens sans les
concevoir dès demain mais quand il y en
a qui avaient beaucoup y aurait beaucoup
de talent mais qu'on voit la conque avec
qui on aimerait on a vous n'avez pas
envie de passer des moments durs qui
vous pensez à qui au nom mais il ya des
gens mais tous ceux qui seront à table
le savent qui vaut mieux ne pas
connaître en milieu des chansons que
j'ai préféré écouter sans connaître
celui qui chante et je m'appelle prévoir
des films sans connaître l'acteur parce
que j'ai vu l'envers et j'ai eu du mal
d'ailleurs à ouvrir les yeux et quand
les oreilles et tu sais qui m'a ouvert
les yeux dans ce métier ça les
maquilleuses ah oui et une idée les
techniciens si tu veux savoir qui est
qui tu demandes à thé caméraman et aux
maquilleuses coiffeuses par ailleurs
demandé tout de suite
vous
qu'est ce que c'est vrai c'est vrai que
monsieur m'a dit que j'étais dis-moi tu
peux tu me dire à moi film là c'est pas
vrai jean michel maire il est sympa en
vrai dans la vie ouais bon lui veut rien
dire allez on va se retrouver au est le
gars le gars